what's happening you bad [__]
it's uncle joey it's a whole new [__]
month
with a whole new set of rules covet is
still alive and kicking
but guess what so are we the joint is
brought to you by
movement watches listen valentine's day
is almost here you're like joey
why are you talking about valentine's
day why because we were just talking
about new year's eve four [__] days
ago
and look what it is it's february 1st
valentine's day is almost here
and you should get your girl a gift from
people who actually know
about good taste like the founders of
movement watches
two college dropouts that took on a
watch industry
with great looking designs and even
better prices
now all movement watches blue light
sunglasses
and jewelry are 20 off their valentine's
day sale
valentine's day is quick listen next
sunday is the [__] super bowl
and the following [__] sunday's
valentine's day and you're gonna be left
there
with your [__] dick in your hand with
no gift together
this is it right here give your girl
something she'll actually like
this year not some [__] cologne or
perfume or [__] flowers
anybody can give you flowers these
watches are tremendous
i have the silver one with the aluminum
band
and i love it these uh glasses to look
at the computer
[__] tremendous they sent me their
finest watch the element international
waters
with a gunmetal gray band this is one
bad [__] and they also sent me a
fine pair of shades dust sunglasses
and blacks they make me look like an old
school [__]
hollywood [__] whatever star movement
watches
are like they cost the whole paycheck
they look like they cost a whole
paycheck
but they cost like they fell off a truck
you understand
me which is cheap get a beautiful watch
shipped to you right now for free if you
don't love it
you send it back no worries if you're
like me
you spend a lot of time in front of a
[__] computer
get some ever scroll blue light glasses
they help with eye strain
bad sleep and headaches plus they look
kind of cool too
so do me a favor use code v day 20
that's v day 20 at checkout to save 20
percent
off on the perfect movement gift for
your loved ones
this valentine's day ladies get your
husband or boyfriend a watch right there
join movement with free shipping free
returns
by going to mvmt dot com slash joey
again
mbmt dot com slash joey
again that's mbmt dot com
slash joey and use v-day 20
for 20 off from movement watches
and the tremendous dust sunglasses in
black
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion listen i've learned about cbd
but the surgery really helped me learn
about cbd
and what it taught me is that cbd lion
is the best this is the tape i'm using
these is the tincture i'm using this
is the gummy i'm [__] eating the same
ones right there
and that's the other tape i'm using
after icing
i put it right around the stitches
around the swelling
you got to see what my leg looks like
now and how i feel
tip top magoo no [__] pain pill
addictions none of that stuff
go to cbdlion.com right now and read up
on cbd
cbn and learn all the benefits that are
available to you
go to cbdlion.com right now and press in
joey or church and get 20 off delivered
right to your [__] house okay
who's better than you no more buying
[__] from people who don't know
dick these people know what they're
talking about that's cbdlion.com right
now
the joint is also brought to you by
onyx.com
the best i've been with them since day
one whether it's the alpha brain
the protein puffs at 15 grams of [__]
little bag
15 grams that's like two [__] eggs
melatonin which helps you sleep
try the lavender [__] tremendous the
powder alpha brain
alpha brain if you don't like it they
give you the product back and you can
keep and they'll send you back your
money
it's shrooms that make you [__] think
and focus
and it helps your memory and it helps
you be a [__] savage
you can buy a bottle go on a cycle and
then tell me what you're thinking how
you feel
suckers go to honor.com right now take a
look at the fine selection that they
have
i can't help you with the kettlebells
and the club bats but i can help you
with the supplements i'll be right there
they got these little peanut butter
chocolate protein bites
seven grams of protein low sugar [__]
tremendous go to honor.com right now
and press in church and get 20
off delivered right to your
[__] house 10
off 20. i don't [__] know just go to
honor.com
you want to start the month off healthy
and right right it starts with on it
let's kick this [__] off right
now
i thought it was a trick candle there
for a second i love you [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
monday the 1st of [__] february
where the [__] did january go we would
just celebrate new year's eve what
four [__] days ago that's how fast
life is [__] moving right now even
think
no things are rough out there and uh
we're still trying to get settled
it's moving that fast life don't give a
[__] about what's going on with you
so that's why you got to catch up i'm
happy you're here on a beautiful
[__] monday morning it's [__]
coming down here in jersey
it's [__] snowing and i love it i got
[__]
umberto coming over to shovel today
because obviously papa can't do it
i love shoveling snow i don't give a
[__] for all you [__]
that were laughing at me and saying i
would move out of jersey after the first
snowstorm
well we're up to number two and i'm
still [__] here [__] so you
can all suck my dick
snow don't care what people never
understood was i already did
18 [__] winters in jersey when it was
really [__] winter
not this [__] climate control [__]
that nothing happens here in november
because now it's a little milder here
and you guys forget i did what 13
real winters in colorado with my first
winter in colorado
being the [__] virgin killer it
snowed 25 [__] days in a row
are you [__] kidding me and you
[__] are trying to tell me
oh he'll leave jersey after it gets cold
go [__] yourself i'm tougher than that
i put 20 [__] years into this cold
weather already this isn't even cold
like they tell you it's going to be uh
bone brick blistering cold weather
my wife is into that she get the hat the
whole [__] thing yesterday on my side
with a hooded sweatshirt walking up and
down the corner
exercising my knee i wasn't cold the sun
was out
about 3 30. i ain't gonna lie to you you
got [__] cold
but at 11 to 12 it was nice out you
could have gone outside and played with
a ball for 30 minutes it was beautiful
so don't let the [__] tv
i i listen weathermen are not always
[__] right i can't stand [__]
leatherman
i [__] want to stab them all because
the weather is
as a night hypothesis which is actually
an educated guess
that means that's why we're like like my
wife is great i'll go to what's the
weather like today
and she'll go in her back pocket and
look at her phone and go
oh it's it's going to be uh 63 degrees
what you couldn't look at the [__]
window
i open up the door and i already tell
you what the [__] weather is i'm no
[__] weather man
i'm not educated to give out the [__]
weather but all you do is you go like
that you go oh it's cloudy in the snow
that's the [__] weather what else is
there to do my wife's in there like
it's 63 degrees then she'll give you
like the 10-day accuweather listen
they can't predict tomorrow how the [__]
are they gonna predict the next 12 days
give me a [__] leave me alone
give me a [__] break anyway thank god
you're here today i want to explain some
stuff
because everything turns into something
and with this podcast
you know the podcast has and then people
hit me with a thousand [__] questions
on what i meant and i got one question
that was [__] brilliant
i got that question over and over again
and i didn't even
imagine it i didn't even see it as i was
coming and
that's how [__] up i've been lately i
didn't even see the window open there
as i was talking about it last week i
was talking about that
i got into a little disagreement with a
guy shotgun doug
when he was embarrassing me and telling
me that i was a jailbird and [__]
and how much i was pissed off because at
that time in 94
i didn't want anybody to know but for
you to understand this story
we have to go back with this there was
nothing
listen my mother died that's a shame god
took
a what are you gonna do you have to move
on try to explain that to a 16 year old
kid
you're not going to now as a 58 year old
adult
i get it people die and you have to move
on
when you're going through it you don't
really [__] know what's going on
you're overwhelmed with pain you know
you're overwhelmed with all this [__]
[__]
you know and i had to do things
after my mother died uh you know
somebody asked me when did you become
you know uh how did you prepare yourself
to become a man
or something like that i became a man
when that ambulance was going down the
corner
with the lights blinking and my mother
was in the back of it that's when i
became a man there was no preparation
you know i went from being a lazy
[__] [__] kid who
you know i don't like peace to you you
better eat those [__] peas because
that's all you got
do you understand me so i never had the
natural course like most young men
that they evolved i became a man when my
mother's when the ambulance
was pulling away of my mother that was
it it was me
alone in the [__] house and after
that i was taken care of you know my
friends took care of me or whatever
i was stupid i was very hard-headed
and i did something that in my world
you had to be a [__] complete loser
to do
even though i knew you had to be a loser
to do it
i did it anyway because that's who i was
and it didn't really matter at that time
what mattered what what was in front of
me
yeah i was going to school and i was
getting an education
and i was getting good grades but i also
had to fend for myself there was no
social security
my mother didn't leave a will there was
no [__] big money coming at me
you know the writer would give me 200 a
week you know
i would work in a hardware store and
make another buck 50
you know i sold drugs i did this i did
everything i could to make ends meet
but by my senior year i knew
opportunities
were around that
high school i don't know
i don't know what happened to me and by
my my senior year
i mean this is how much of a loser i am
that i quit the beginning of my senior
year
like i went to school for like a week
and quit my senior year
that's like quitting comedy after 10
years once you
you've already done the grunt work
that's like quitting
the nba after one season that that that
is just
the dumbest [__] thing a human being
could ever do
but i did it when i did that
i felt [__] terrible i had a job at
mass back i don't want you to think i
quit
just for the center quitting i quit
because i had a job that offered me 20
something dollars an hour 18 an hour at
the time
something [__] crazy you know
and uh i
i worked it for two months and then they
promoted me
to a night uh whatever and i had to work
till five in the morning and i could
never get
so i just said you know what man let me
get this job
let me uh you know try to make some of
myself danny and listen i started down
there
as a warehouse man and it was a
temporary position for 30 days and it
was
very very hard to make the union the guy
who was in charge
of you of making the decision about you
was a real [__] prick but
he may not have liked me he might not
like how i dressed
my hair whatever that was spanish
whatever the [__] it was
but one thing he definitely liked about
me
was the way i worked when i got that job
i knew there was no more [__] [__]
footing
so i went in there head first i did
everything i had to do i got the job
like in
the beginning of july 81. and
you know it was like i think it was like
11 bucks to start or something like that
something just [__] crazy and i went
in there dog if my shift was from
10 in the morning to 6 at night i worked
from [__] nine
to seven i was [__] there and
whatever jobs i picked were the ones
that made you lift the most like if it
was
chains and electrical wiring mass back
hardware
mass back sentry with hardware was a
hardware chain
and that's what they had so i would
carry all the big stuff
90 bag concrete i would always volunteer
for those pallets
so boom i made the union and then like
two or three weeks after i make the
[__] union a job opens up
for a night loader it was gravy it was
seven
to four they had overtime maybe two or
three nights a week till six
but on fridays you worked eight
to seven to eight and you got paid for
[__] the whole eight hours
so i had to [__] take the job i put
my name on the list
just like anybody else they [__] you
know i was like
i'm number one i'm not gonna get it it
was based on seniority
on how much how long you had been there
bro
out of the skin of my teeth i nailed the
job
i got the [__] job and i was after
august
i started making money i was able to pay
some bills
i was able to buy some clothes i was
able to do things i hadn't been able to
do
because i was a little [__] too crazy
or whatever it was like overwhelming
money
it wasn't little pieces that i was
getting you know five days a week it was
overwhelming i want
so for the first time i get my clothes
for the first time i could buy a winter
jacket you know
and if you think i'm [__] you know i
was on my own
at [__] 18 already so once school was
gonna start
the first week i went back and i loaded
trucks
and i think i went to a couple classes
but
i couldn't do it i couldn't do it and
because my first class was at 7
30. i was part of the cie work study
program
so that means that i would go to school
from 7 30 to 12 30
and then go to my job but everything had
switched i had gotten a new job and
everything that's right so
the day i decided to quit high school
i went on a [__] coke binge for three
days
because in my world that was the [__]
lowest thing i could do
never mind the houses i was burglarizing
never mind the drugs never mind all that
[__] that i was
already embarrassed about but here i was
doing the thing i believed
that made you the biggest [__] loser
in the world
quit in [__] high school and a good
friend of mine did it
he was like a brother to me he quit
because his family had a fruit company
and he was getting groomed to take over
the company okay then you quit
you're going to be a [__]
multi-millionaire someday but i didn't
have the same opportunities i just saw
that he was doing great i thought about
it
and against all my wishes and everything
i [__] quit
i quit [__] high school and you guys
have no idea
how bad that made me feel till today
i feel a little bit bad about it but i
ended up doing something with my life
and i got my ged
so it doesn't sting as much as it did
but at that time guys
i can't tell you how much that bothered
me and you don't even know what pain is
you don't want me to tell you what pain
really is the first thanksgiving after
high school
and you know i went to the bar to sell
[__] coke obviously right me and my
friends are selling coke
and all sudden all these kids i was in
high school with
were coming home from [__] that first
semester of college
for thanksgiving break and i remember
being at that [__] bar that night
and they're all talking about their
colleges and their fraternities and
their sororities
and here i am sitting with my loser
friends selling coke
you do you have any idea what a loser
feels like i felt like a [__] loser
that night
you watched the movie [__] saint
elmo's fire
when rob lowe goes back up to the school
and [__]
one of the k guys says to him hey man i
don't know what you're gonna stay up
here for
and he goes i don't know i'm not sure i
just came up and he goes we love it when
you're here because we get all the good
drugs
there's a look on his face and that's
the exact feeling i had that night
like that's all i was good for was to
sell [__] drugs here's all the kids
that i've known for 10 years
now they're all in [__] college and
me and my three loser buddies are
sitting at the bar drinking
thinking we're [__] cool you ain't
that [__] cool i wasn't that [__]
cool
so i want you to understand the
embarrassment
i had when i quit high school because of
where i came from where i'm coming from
that is like
the worst thing you could do that's like
just [__] tattooing
a loser l right on your [__] forehead
and i did it anyway so i lived with that
and i felt terrible
when i got a chance to get out of north
bergen i went to colorado
why do you think i went to colorado
mountain college
why do you think i took those classes
because i love knowledge
i love learning till today till this day
i love learning something new
somebody i just met with a girl friday a
dear friend of mine erica and her family
and she gave me a book that she had
written about you know success and
motivation i started reading it i love
learning
[__] at 58 i still love
sitting down and reading but learning
reading reading something about weight
loss or diabetes or
you know i didn't look at the [__]
anything about the knee surgery till
after i had the knee surgery
because if i would have read up on it
then i would have been too much of a
[__]
but now i've been reading up on it i
love learning
i love what i just went through what i
just went through with the surgery and
how people tell you oh
be careful you're gonna get hooked on
the drug pills i
[__] didn't want to get hooked on
drug pills i love
how i learned that i had like a system i
had to take my [__]
a pain pill at nine i had to take my cbd
at ten
i had to take my hat you know like i was
always in front of the pain
somebody talked to me on patreon there
were pharmacists and they were like you
want to stay on top of the pain
so i loved what i learned so now when
somebody else has surgery
i could pass it on to them what i
learned not by reading a book
from [__] experience i learned how to
use the [__] tape
around the wound you know i had tins
those things that
give you electroshock i would do those
before mike came today
i told him call me from the wawa because
i'm gonna ice my niece
when i sit here you know i'm gonna be
here for an hour i don't want it to get
stuck on me and whatnot i
learned how to work with the pain do i
look [__] stoned to you do i look
[__] high to you or whatever
no because i took aspirins instead of
pain medication
so i wouldn't have to get hooked on it
so now i can take it at night i'll take
my medication for
for [__] the news tonight or
something like that whatever the [__] i
watch at eight
i'll take it at eight so it doesn't
interfere with my sleep the word is i
love
knowledge so for me to quit high school
it destroyed my basic insides
so now let's let's go back to [__]
everything that's going on here
i lost faith in [__] god okay when my
mother died because
what kind of a god takes away a mother
from a 16 year old kid
i [__] lost faith in myself when i
got the ged
and now guess what eight years later
i'm in a [__] prison cell so
i had two recipes by the age of
25 this is why again i'm talking to you
from experience this isn't a book this
isn't a [__]
self-help book this isn't a life coach
telling you let me tell you something
you don't know how bad it is
when they throw you in a jail cell and
here you are
in jail with a loser tattoo from being
in prison and a matching i had two
matching elves over here loser for
prison
and loser for quitting high school i
just should have just had extensions
on my [__] eyebrows and put two l's
looking at each other
because that's what dawg after you got a
ged
and you're in prison there ain't much
hope left
there ain't much hope left the only hope
you have is the [__]
hopefully they'll hire a subway to sell
[__] shark skin
tuna sandwiches did you see that [__]
even the tuna ain't [__] real
didn't i tell you [__] 10 years
ago remember when i used to torture lee
that the [__] turkeys yeah it could
be turkey meat but
it's probably one of those turkeys that
got hit by a [__] car it ain't a
quality [__] turkey
now they're getting sued for using shark
meat and monkey meat
as [__] tuna you guys are gonna tell
me my [__] business
you're gonna tell me my [__] business
that's why i didn't want to end up in a
[__] subway
so i had two capital l's how my house
how much
how much shame can somebody have i quit
high school
and i went to and i had a felony i had
no prospects
i had no prior you talk to somebody i
got a couple things going on
you know my uncle's gonna get me into
the union i had
nothing i had no prospects when you got
a felony and you're a ged [__]
and you're a dropout there ain't much in
your [__] world
unless you know somebody unless you suck
a really good [__] or unless you got a
big [__] with cushing in it
and ice cubes or something you ain't got
a future
you don't have too much of a future so
here i am
in 1989 i'm a [__] dropout
and a felon i'm in the halfway house
you know listen i made a plan when i was
in [__] prison i made a plan
i made a promise to myself the same
promise i made in 2007
when i didn't when i stopped snorting
coke and that's the reason i'm off coke
today
i made myself a promise in 1988.
before i went to reconsideration in 1989
january 20th i said to myself that if i
would [__] him
if i get out of here
even though i'm mad at god whoever the
[__] god is
better yet i said i'll swear to the
universe
that i'll do everything in my power not
to be a millionaire
not to have a yacht not to have a testo
rosa
not to be that guy with the izad shirt
trying to be cool
i just want it to be not
a loser you ever just want to not be a
[__] loser
i didn't care about millionaire or a
house even if i slept on a
couch i just didn't want to be a loser
i just wanted to end this up with
[__] i just wanted this to end
with me having a regular job
i didn't even care about a pension i
didn't think i was going to make it to
58 anyway
but i just didn't want to be a loser
that's why i went out doug that day
because i was so embarrassed that he
told me
i was a [__] you know a felon and
then my ex-wife told me something one
day when i went to pick up the kid
didn't you realize what you did you're a
[__] felon
but you're just not a regular felon you
threw a person in a trunk of a car
for years i lived with that [__]
remorse
if you don't think i'm i [__] feel
bad about some of the things i did
today as a 58 year old but you got
another thing coming i goof around here
i make listen i make dark situations
funny so i could get over them and it
says a form of therapy
but some of the things i did still
bother me very much today
very much the ged not that much because
i did something in my life
and i ended up you know trying i ended
up going you know i got my ged
which doesn't really [__] count in my
book
high school is high school but it works
for now
and i ended up taking you know seven
eight [__] semesters of college
you know what for a guy like me where i
came from
i could [__] live with that so i
didn't [__] talk about it now you
also got to say well joey
in 1994 weren't you doing comedy
yes i was but half the [__] that i tell
you people over the last 10 years
i wouldn't even dare bring up i wouldn't
even
dare bring up i didn't have the balls
to tell you guys i had been in prison
that
you know had a ged that in 1993 in the
middle of comedy in the middle of
everything i stole a [__] change jar
from a carvel in fort lee i would have
never told you these things
that those are all [__] marks of a
loser
okay so yes in 1994
i was going up on that stage and not
talking about these things
so for you comics that are watching this
or comments for the
young comics that are listening to this
this is where it comes in for you
i wasn't talking about this on stage
none of these stories i tell today
kidnapping you know uh rob robin michael
jewelers
robbin this doing about this i never
mentioned those stories
why do you think because they were
[__] i was ashamed of them
i was actually ashamed of my [__]
life so
my first couple years of comedy we were
not doing this
we were going up there telling
knock-knock [__] jokes as a matter of
fact
for 10 years of my comedy i was going up
there and doing knock-knock jokes as a
matter of fact
for maybe 13 to 14 years of comedy
i went up there and knock-knocked you
and did knock-knock jokes
when did i become successful as a comic
when they heard these stories when i
finally opened up
about being a criminal when i opened up
about even the tedious
most disgusting [__] you could say
that's when i became a real comic
but i didn't know that i didn't know
that then
so for 94 95
i tiptoed my way around that when i met
other comics
i didn't tell them i went to prison what
are you crazy
i didn't want them to use it against me
they would use it against me
the same way they used the five dollars
at the [__] comedy competition
against me
if i tell these people i quit high
school they're gonna lose it against me
if i tell these people that i rob the
change jar
from [__] carville ice cream they're
gonna use it against me
that's that's how i [__] live my life
i was at the store in 97
and i still wasn't talking about prison
i wasn't talking about none of this
stuff because i
i dated a girl for [__] two years i
dated a girl for
four years and she didn't find out until
like 18
months that i had gone to prison
that's how ashamed ever that was
and then a couple things happen i
watched the stupid movie
called family business and
he told them he told the matthew brother
he tells sean connery
he's going to prison and he goes ah
don't worry about it it's like a hitch
in the army
it builds character and i'm like well
it did help me build some [__]
character
you know but i'm still not gonna [__]
say it i'm still not gonna [__] talk
about it
you know i was very i was just [__]
brutally ashamed
you know there was just a thousand and
one things i had done that
i didn't you know i didn't even die like
i would never
ever tell you people that i [__] used
to go into a [__] kmart and bring
back receipts
how low life is that that's that's as
little life as could get
but that's what my life was that's a
reality of it that's what my life was
if i never told you that story you guys
would have never known about it
and i would have been just fine but no i
wanted you to know
i wanted you guys to know everything
to see exactly and know exactly every
step
that i went through every step of the
way and everything i did that i went
through
every step of pain everything so for
[__] 95
96 97
but then in 97 something happened
i used to have these articles okay
because i was
i was doing comedy and i was doing these
triple runs and by 96
i was doing okay but what i would read
in those days
was i would read this comedy newspaper
i'm sorry i've talked about it before in
the church
i forget what it was called it was put
out by john fox in san francisco
and it was written by a bunch of comics
they probably got paid dick or nothing
at all
and they used it as writing assignments
which is what you do in the beginning
and it just broke down comedy it was
just a comedy newspaper
that every week it just broke down
comedy you know what clubs were hot
it interviewed a certain comic it
interviewed a comedy club owner
and interviewed bookers it just let you
know the ins and outs of comedy
it was a pretty cute little [__]
black and white
and it was free it was at all the comedy
clubs and
one month they had where they
interviewed tim allen
and i read the interview and it talked
about how
he had gone to prison and i was blown
the [__] away
i was blown the [__] away
i knew lenny bruce had been in jail you
know like prior had been arrested
people had been arrested that's not what
i was
relating to [__] tim allen
did time so i was like
oh thank god and then when he got a deal
from disney
i was like oh
there's one guy could relate to so
i went from being a hicks
kennison dice prior guy
and i reworked it and went all of that
way back
to the early early beginnings
of timeout his showtime specials
he did a couple showtime things i forget
what the name
i'm really sorry guys with memory and
all that stuff even though i take the
alpha brain
there's just so many [__] specials
that i have seen in comedy
that by now i forget but all men or
whatever
he did like uh
he did you know those like i did the
degenerates
for netflix he did one of those for
showtime
with other people i think correct me
or uh fact check me
i'm like trump now you gotta fact check
me now when i do these things cause i
don't
and i don't want you to fact check me
because i'm lying i want you to fact
check me
to tell me to to tell me what the [__]
is going on
man of pigs was that wasn't what he did
for showtime
i'll show you because he came on
showtime first not hbo
he was a showtime guy i always thought
hbo was the way to go on my showtime
that's for [__] the b league showtime
hbo is the way to go
but when tim allen did the [__]
you know the when i found out that he
had been to prison i go [__] it
i gotta follow this guy i gotta find
there was no internet
you know it wasn't like the speed of the
internet that we have today
with all the information so i just went
down what did you find out
his dirtiest dozen commies dirty a dozen
and then
pigs opening night at rodney's place
there you go
rewires america there you go and this
all is on show time
yeah so that's what it was so i had a
retrace but it was whatever he did
before 98
99 so i had to dig into showtime i
didn't have [__] showtime
so thank god at the video store i went
to
i asked one of the guys like there was
one actual video
of tim allen's but he was a tim allen
fan
and he goes i got a bunch of stuff on
vhs i'll lend you
you have to give it back to me at the
end of the weekend so i go give it all
to me
and i looked at all of it all of it all
of it all of it all of it all of it
and i didn't find anything about prison
so i'm like okay maybe you're not
supposed to talk about it
on stage maybe you don't have to talk
about prison or whatever
but they let you be a stand-up comic no
matter how you look at it
at least i had somebody who was
relatable to me
at least i had somebody i could relate
to
okay he became my new fan
i i tried to watch tool time you know i
think it was in this
was it is that name of it i don't know i
tried to watch full-time
home improvement i'm really sorry i was
showing the show that was the show in
the show
i really became a fan of his and i
really liked them
i had never seen them out you know at
the comedy store
or at the improv i had never seen tim
allen out
but i just knew that okay if tim allen
did
prison and he got a deal from disney
i'll be okay we'll figure it out if we
ever get to that far
i didn't you know i didn't look at it i
didn't
in those days i wasn't looking to be on
tv
or looking to be a [__]
movie star i wasn't looking to do
anything i was just looking
for a life i was just looking for
something new to do you know
so i moved to l.a in 97 i became friends
with joe
you know after six or seven months
i told joe you know and i might keep it
under a hat and he's like why and i'm
like just
keep it on their hat you know i don't
really
want people to know i told very few
people like i told ralphie
you know i told like hari when i met
hari
that i had done some time i wasn't
specific like i would just tell people i
did time
they would say for what and i would just
go burglarizing
i never really opened up about the
[__] kidnapping like i didn't have
the balls
to say a story about it like once i was
done with it i was done with it
and to be honest with yourself i was
just doing myself a disservice
because i wasn't talking about the [__]
people wanted to hear
people wanted to hear about you know
stand-up comedy
is uh my my world collides with the rest
of the world
and that's what people want to hear they
didn't want to hear the [__] stupid
knock-knock jokes i was saying
up to 2013. you know
after 98
i started dabbing and more like
i think 98 was the first time i brought
cocaine up on stage
like i didn't want people to know about
my coke habit
so i wasn't talking about coke and
[__] but when i was an open mic on
all those years
i didn't talk about coke i didn't talk
about prison
i didn't talk about moms dying i didn't
talk about criminal acts
i think i talked a little bit about
sports betting maybe early and
oh yeah i had a i had a joke in seattle
what's your favorite team
the joke who covers the spread most
people go to a game with a hat with a
a team on it i go to i go to a game with
a hat with a minus three on it
i mean that was the only [__] thing
that i had in my act was maybe about
gambling
but none of this [__] that you hear on
here i was too
[__] embarrassed to even talk about
it
so let me tell you how life takes care
of you
if you don't commit 100 to your [__]
whatever you're thinking of doing
it's not going to work out for you how
do i know because i know
because when you commit life takes care
of you
i'm doing my stand-up comedy it's about
uh
it's about february or march of 99.
i just got back from like a 14-month
road gig
14 months on the road
i think i had maybe two weeks in l.a
uh the road trip had started like
early 98 and it just went
it started like christmas of 97.
i took a beating one night i had to
follow doug stanhope
at the improv on a monday night i got
sandwiched in between doug stand open
nick
apollo and it didn't go too well for
uncle joey
and i said [__] this i can't keep
bombing like this in l.a
i have to go out on the road and improve
a little bit so i
got a job [__] selling screws and
[__]
and they had a fax machine i had a job
out to be that [__] four in the
morning
selling screws on ivar and off of
hollywood boulevard
so i would snort coke at night come down
and sit
behind the comedy store to four and then
i would drive over to the
because four o'clock l a time is seven
a.m california time
so i would have to sell screws to people
on the
east coast and i started using their
phone number
and they had a long distance phone
obviously
and their fax number and i started
booking [__] work
and i got busy i actually started
booking work and i put together a tour
and i [__] left for like 14 [__]
months
so now i'm back in l.a it's march of 99.
i'm sitting there one day and i get a
force from i get a call
from a lady comic named diane ford
look her up she's on youtube very
[__] funny
very sweet lady i don't know how the
[__] she got my number
but she called me and she says to me
that uh
she has a dirty show she's booking at
the sahara at the time
and if i wanted to be one of the three
comics i
i still remember what it paid it paid
for two shows which is more money than
i'd ever seen in my [__] life
so i paid 1500 bucks a hotel
and they gave you 100 daily a hundred
dollars a day to eat
at the time i'm making 15 a night at the
comedy store
fifteen hundred dollars but there was a
catch
i had to wear a tuxedo i'm like god
damn it what the [__] is wrong with me i
gotta [__] put on a tuxedo
so i didn't have money for no [__]
tuxedo where am i gonna get a tuxedo
from you gotta give me the 1500 first
to get a tuxedo so i went to my
brother's doug stanhope he's the master
of [__] suits
and i go doug where do i get a tuxedo
and he goes
just go right down the corner to melrose
right off of melrose boulevard over
there they sell
tuxedos it's like a second-hand store
and i walked in and i got a nice one i
got like a [__] you know
the black with the [__] nice i look
like one of those [__] waiters in a
nice restaurant
i think it was like for the cumberbund
the whole [__] thing
and i was huge that i looked like wayne
newton before the operation i look like
i was
99 i was maybe 300 pounds
but no lifting body just a [__] gut
and [__]
so i get this [__] i mean i'm
stressed about the tuxedo
the date is in july i get booked in
march
the date is in july
so it's supposed to be me david towel
and somebody else uh the other comic was
just as big as david tell me i was a
feature act i was a glorified
feature act i was funny i was dirty
i was working out of the comedy store
and it was 99
um i had shot the pilot for cbs
i had shot basketball
ah you know
i was halfway there did you ever hear
about how rogan
tells that he hung out with me and that
for two or three years i was struggling
and one day i got really funny
remember he talks about that he said it
a thousand times in his podcast
pay attention so i'm supposed to work
at the desert in with uh
tell and i think it was maybe louis ck
or somebody like that
and i call her up the week of the gig
and
she goes you're still on you're
confirmed your hotel room will be ready
three o'clock on friday i had no car a
dear friend of mine drove me
i miss him dearly i don't know where he
is today
and i remember a dear friend of mine
from houston who i still talked to
nothing sexual she was just a dear
friend i was so nervous
it was my first time performing in vegas
you know i was performing with dave
attell and louis ck
you know i had met i think i was friends
with louis ck already
i met louis ck in 95 in seattle
i don't think i met a tell but i was a
huge [__] fan of his
that's when he had that joke about uh
you know who likes fireworks raise your
hooks
you know like all that [__] you know i
was [__] dying you know i love david
tell
i'm [__] all excited to work with
david tell i called diane ford to check
in
what do you think diane ford says to me
she's like i'm happy you called
you're confirmed blah blah blah the
other two comments canceled
i go god damn it there's my chance to
work with dave [__] to tell
god damn it i'm a [__] fan
i [__] dying to work with them i've
watched them but to work with them and
to maybe talk to them a little bit
and to [__] learn [__]
so you know what it has nothing to do
with me man i got a job
i'm gonna pick up 1500 bucks i could pay
the attorney i could pay child support
i could snort coke oh at lea
you know you know what i'm saying all my
[__] problems are solved you know
what that in those days i had 18 [__]
hands to [__] plum every time i got a
check every time i got a check i had a
grease
18 palms and 10 of them were palms that
i wanted to kill
my ex-wife the attorneys [__] child
support
you know it never [__] stopped in
those days so
i don't worry about who's gonna be on
the bill i don't even think about it
okay no big [__] deal
i [__] drive to vegas
i get out of the car i go to my hotel
room
i go upstairs
uh diane ford calls me and she goes the
show's late
o'clock be there at 7 30. you know in
that whole
conversation i did not ask her
who i was working with or who were the
replacements with
i never even [__] seen it coming
i put my [__] tuxedo on i look like a
a two pound baloney in a one pound bag
you know my [__] tuxedo
and i walk to the green room
when i walked into the green room there
was one comic in there
and the comic's name was tim allen
it's [__] tim allen [__] shining
his shoes
you know like a guy has a foot up on a
counter
and they're shining their shoes he's
[__] shining his shoes and i'm like
oh my god i felt like one of those [__]
when it rains on the gay pride
like i just started sweating
profusiously like somebody rained on my
parade
like i'm saying this because one time i
was living in hollywood and it rained
during gay pride
and i saw one of the gay guys live down
the block from me and i saw him with his
little flower [__] all [__] up
and he was like somebody rained on my
parade so i was laughing about that
that's right
bro i saw tim allen i was like what the
[__] is this
and then it was me tim allen and vinnie
favorito a kid out of boston he's
back in boston now let me tell you
something man i'm gonna say nothing
diane ford came in and she goes tim
allen joey diaz joey diaz tim allen we
shook hands
i didn't say nothing in fact he [__]
came to me and he's like hey man
can you do extra time and i'm like yeah
why
because i haven't been on stage in
months i don't know what this is going
to be like and i'm like i got you
don't worry about nothing i didn't play
him i didn't try to be [__] cute
i just shut my mouth and i drank my
water
you know i just so happened to go on
stage that night and by the luck of god
i leveled the [__] room and he came
over to me and said that was great kid
and how long have you been doing this
and i told him you know it took like
about an hour or so and i guess
i think we went back to his room he said
do you want to come back to the room and
get something to eat
so we get back to the room and after
about an hour i try you know
you try to control yourself you know you
try not to be a half a [__]
and go i'm a huge fan you know i went to
prison you know
so after about an hour or so i think
maybe the next night
i said then you know uh
listen i just want to tell you something
that you
helped me get from point a to point b
you were like my federal express
i go i had a felony i went to prison
and i got into comedy and then i
realized that you know i
i had a felony how
far could i go make this a career i
didn't know if clubs did background
checks you know i just didn't know at
that time
and uh once i saw that you had gone to
prison
it made my life my life a lot easier i
go i'm such a fan of yours
that when i had a pick um what city to
go on the road first
i picked detroit out of homage to you
i go like in fact i even tried to play
mark ridley's
comedy club but they said i was a bit
too dirty
and he's like [__] up you know like he
was really cool at that
and he goes uh i told my i ended up
playing dearborn joey's and dearborn
and that you know if it wasn't for him
then it was the truth
because kennison pry all those guys had
inspired me to do stand-up
but once you know i went to prison it
was completely different
and i told him i had gone to prison and
i don't know what happened
we went into a full [__] hour talk
and he told me the importance of being
honest on stage
and letting your audience know the truth
he goes tell him
tell him make jokes around it right
around it
he goes you don't want to not tell him
because that's
part of who you are you know you quit
high school you know i told them the
same story i'm telling you guys
you know you quit in high school that's
part of who you are today
it's in your dna it's a part of who you
are it's part of your persona on stage
you got to tell them everything and then
some you just can't tell them a little
bit of your life
if you open that door you got it's like
you know when you when you're writing
they say not to open up a door unless
you're going to close it
so if you're going to open up that
[__] door you better open up that
[__] door
you know when if you listen to
podcasting i started with beauty and the
beast
same thing happened there it was just
two people talking
until one day i told the story about
mugging the hooker
and light her wig on fire and everything
changed
everything changed because my guts came
out
my guts came out now you become indebted
to me
so you know i found that at that point
when i had to talk with tim allen that
what the [__] was going on now two
things happened
that summer me and that girl broke up
and i had that talk with tim allen
me and the crazy stripper girl broke up
who i just spoke to a couple days ago
she's doing great
i still love her to death 20 years later
without her
i would have never got to la but we
broke up we weren't getting along you
know
my expectations of l.a her of la and her
expectations
were completely different uh but
that's where joe rogan says he got
really [__] funny i don't know where
i don't know what happened why a
i became honest on stage and b i stopped
dating that girl
most of my energy was focused on her but
let's not blame her
let's not blame her let's blame tim
allen
for telling me to be honest on stage
that was the most important thing and
that's why when i'm doing podcasts
when i'm on [__] stage i don't give a
[__]
i don't give a [__] if somebody like
something i'll tell you
you know everything i already did just
by us
talking here there's a couple things i
left out because it involves certain
people
or it would sink somebody else's name in
it
but anything i've done i've brought to
the stage
whether it be the performing stage
or the podcast stage because nothing
should be held back
so if you're a comic and you have like
an
uncle who's a junkie but you're scared
about talking about him
[__] him talk about him it's his fault
he's snorting glue ain't got nothing to
do with you
if he wants to be an idiot in droob on
his [__] shirt
you gotta talk about it nothing
is yeah yeah it's the truth nothing is
sacred
so that shame that i had over [__]
quit in high school
and [__] you know you just you're
just ashamed about things
don't ever be ashamed about them first
of all you can't [__] bring him back
there's nothing i could do to undo that
[__] belt nothing i could do
it's done i did it and i move forward
until i can became honest with it i
wasn't moving forward
think about that well i didn't say no to
nobody
today you guys know everything about me
you guys know
everything about me the only thing i've
never gotten into you guys has
been like the death of my father like
the real death of my father i'm saving
for the book
you know there's a couple things i got
to hold back but you guys know
everything i did no matter how bad
or how good it is i don't give a [__]
because it's
who you are and when you're doing
stand-up
it's [__] crucial it's crucial
to be [__] honest on
[__] stage when you're on stage who
the [__] are you talking to who do you
think you're talking to
do you really think you're talking to an
audience
you as a comic are talking to ghosts
you never knew that you never knew that
that's what you're talking to
you're taking all the skeletons out of
your [__] closet when you're
when you want to be that good you have
to compare the skeletons in your closet
to the skeletons that are going on in
life right now if that's the simplest
way to put it for you
so if you ever wondered why i was that
much of ashamed
it's because dog think about being 25
already having two felonies and being a
high school dropout
what the [__] are your chances
i had no chance this is why i tell you
people i shouldn't be here
this is why i did the podcast couple
weeks ago about
at 58 where i thought i would be i
thought i would be in [__] prison
because i had no future at 25
or at least i thought that
that's the only person who thought that
me nobody else around me thought that
some of you guys do some of you younger
guys do
that if you guys have one mark against
you
when you're 23 you don't have a life and
that's
[__] don't let a felony
a dui you made a mistake
you made a mistake i made a mistake as a
kid
yeah i knew what i was doing when i
kidnapped bella i'm not going to lie to
you and tell you i didn't know what i
was doing
it was a mistake how do i know it was a
mistake because it was never done again
so now today i come out here and i talk
about it and we goof about it
and i have a great time and everybody's
[__] happy do you think i'm ashamed
about what i did to valor
now today in 2021
i'm a little bit ashamed i did that to
another human being
but i'm not as ashamed as i was in 1999
you know 12 years after it happened i
was living like you know
they [__] like i'm living under the
[__] behind the corners
they know i'm doing this they know i did
it no
and that set me free and that made me
the comic
that i am today tell the truth whatever
the [__] happened in your past
it was the [__] past who gives a [__]
nobody really gives a [__] at the end of
the week do you think anybody gives a
[__] now today that mike tyson
raped the chick 20 years ago have you
heard somebody bring it up
do you think anybody gives a [__] about
michael vick with the dogs that happened
10 years ago
no no do you think you know only
but i guarantee you
not mike tyson as much as michael vick
it stays in your head
it's it's basically new it's 10 years
ago you know when that went down michael
vick
10 12 13 years ago i guarantee you might
i'm not upset over the kidnapping no
more i'm ashamed to have a felony i'm
ashamed that i'm not
a proper american because of the felony
but guess what
the felony isn't what i was worried
about it was the truth that you guys
needed to hear
that's the most important thing if
you're a stand-up
write that [__] down when you go up
on stage
tell the truth tell the truth and tell
the most
if you really want to get over a hump in
your life tell the most disturbing thing
in your life to an audience that'll ease
bombing
when you're telling an audience one of
your utmost
deepest secrets bombing doesn't really
matter
after that you're like ah
who gives a [__] about bombing i told
him the other that i got [__] in the
ass with a cucumber in the eighth grade
who cares about bombing do you see what
i'm saying to you that's worse than
bombing
sometimes saying the truth is worse than
[__] bombing
so this stan this podcast was more for
comics than for
you know general people but i i hope you
get something out of this podcast too
just tell the truth there's nothing to
be ashamed of if you're planning on
redeeming yourself who gives a [__]
i always had um plans on redeeming
myself
not this way i always thought i would
come through in a different
manner not this way but today who gave
us a [__] about the 1986
kidnapping of ken bella not me
i don't even think kent gives a [__]
about no more if you want i'll call him
and ask him for you
i don't think he even gives a [__] about
it no more you know
that's why it bothered me sometimes that
mike who's mad at louis ck today
nobody is there anybody you know all
those people that made such a big fuss
is there any of those people that ever
called the girls and see how they're
doing today not really
and i bet both of those girls are doing
great today too you know
we think what's that we make things
worse
than they are in our mind sometimes i
know i did so
if you got anything from today's
podcasters just tell the [__] truth
what do you got to be ashamed of who
gives a [__]
and you're going to ruin it with a
[__] that's when i really put it all
together
after talking to [__] tim allen and
then the woolly nelson line and the
thief
lie to nobody who the [__] are they that
you have to lie them to
if they're a friend of yours you're
going to ruin it with a lie and if not
again who the [__] are they that you got
a lie to him
that's it and that's that it's monday
february 1st and all we're trying to do
is have a better life and be better
every [__] day
so i hope that's a great lesson for you
on a beautiful monday morning
before you go there's something like i
gotta do i do this a lot on patreon
but i wanted to do it on here today
because i just wanted to i was talking
to a friend of mine
ever since i was in jersey i moved to
jersey
i have a lot of friends that talk to me
about medical marijuana they're like
what's going on medical marijuana
you know like not medical marijuana but
a lot of people now since they legalized
it in
jersey they've been people have been
asking me like
what am i gonna expect and i do a
segment on
patreon just about weed one day a week
you know once every two weeks i'll put a
video up about a product that i really
like
whether it's uh what do we do like the
sprays
we did the abx abx capsules
you know uh something else which one
maven you know today i'm going to give
you an another little gift
this is one of my favorite about a uh
a year and a half ago i came to new york
to shoot the sopranos
and i went to urban trees and i bought
the mavens and stuff like that
and they had a special the guy said to
me that's some pretty good weed
it's made by this company ziki who i've
ended up loving
uh he goes it's an ounce i think it's
two and a quarter which is special
so i was coming home for three weeks i
had like two or three ounces but i go
you know what
i like to give away a lot of weed to
some of my friends people on this set
give me an ounce of that may of this
kiwi uh ziki
kiwi ziki give me an ounce of the ziki
and i'll just give it away to my friends
people on the set
you know it's i didn't know it was
this good of weed so i brought it back
with me i put it in the boxing glove
and i flew back and one day i actually
went to kick box
i wanted a boxing glove and i'm like
holy [__] i got an ounce of weed in here
it was a big bag
and you know i think this one is
the soda [__] let me tell you
something
i took that bag i had brought so much
weed with me
that i just gave away the weed i had
when i found this
in the bag in the boxing glove that
kickboxing oh
i'll start smoking this now i put it in
the second compartment
and you know what the following week i
didn't need that weave
i didn't smoke my ziki weed until i got
back to la
one night i ran out of wheat and i go oh
i got that ounce in the bag
when i opened up this little [__] bag
it was [__] tremendous just looking
at the wheat i go
wow it had like that green to it and i
[__]
broke it up and i [__] smoked and i
was stoned to the [__] gills and here
i am
going i had all that other weed that i
thought was really good
this one beats all of them up so i
started looking into this more and more
and i started
and you start when you go for weed for
all you guys that travel
in colorado vegas california
and you get off off the plane and you
look at a box
and the way it's packaged you're like oh
my god
that's so cool well that's so mister
that's so cool
that box with all those designs are 90
[__] dollars
for three and a half grams just because
they give you a little tray and they box
it up and they put a wrapper around it
and they tell you what the percentage is
and all that [__] suckers like you
pay 90 but you'll see something like
this
and you'll go i'm not gonna get this but
in the meantime
this is the [__] that you're looking for
it's tzatziki
now i do this thing on patreon i'm doing
it for you guys this week
because i love you because i want you to
every everybody who smokes [__] dope
that i know
and everybody's a [__] professional i
got to assume this
is the [__] wheat you want to
be smoking do they tell you what
percentage it is and here or anything
nothing they don't tell you nothing
that's when you know our company is
deadly let me
tell you you decide for yourself what
the strength is
it's very easy you just open up this
little pouch
it stays in the pouch see they don't
spend
their money and all that other [__] that
knuckleheads
getting [__] all you know creepy over
they spend their money on reefer
that's what their money is
and the only thing that's in here is a
little stay fresh
thing this keeps your reefer nice and
fresh and moist
you put that back in there
and there's nowhere on this envelope
where it tells you 34
28 you don't need to know
[__] that's the way ziki wants you to
have this a surprise
so if you're in the california area
because i know for sure
they carry this at urban trees i've been
holding these for months
i just bought like 25 000 of these
things and i just saved my god i'm
scattered all over
and when things get deep i go to my
[__] ziki
they got a [__] what's the one i gave
you this
the d-33 was this
c4 oh my god they got not they got a pb
and cuz or something like that the one i
posted yesterday
two days ago on twitter and this one the
[__]
cola they got one that's a [__] icy
that'll [__] kill you do you
understand me it'll [__] kill you
so if you go to urban trees or any other
dispensary and you see the ziki
you [__] pick it up whether it's icee
cola
what is that c4 through your door
whatever the [__] you want
this is the weed right here that [__]
this is the weed
that trump had this weed they gave trump
to get him out of the white house
how did they got trump out of the white
house he's like i'm not going nowhere
recount pennsylvania they're like trumpy
donald baby come on relax
just take a hit off this we're going to
mar-a-lago it's going to be all right
i'm telling you recount pennsylvania
donny baby come on this is the wee trump
smoke
he's happy again you haven't heard from
it in a week
he's tweeting to the martians
yeah this is what they gave him he was
yelling he ain't going nowhere
donny baby come on we got a little ziki
weed for you there
the rest is history i love you
[__]
have a great week if it's snow and stay
home
mind your business nobody knows nothing
stay black thank you
for watching uncle joey's joining now
for a word from my sponsors [__]
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you for paying attention today
and listening and for [__] being here
and supporting me whether it's
on the joint patreon twitter facebook
coming to the shows
whatever the [__] you do i love you
either way but anyway before we get out
of here
the joint is brought to you by anik
listen
i've been with on it for years i know
the owners
i know how hard aubry works
and this is a product that you cannot
[__] turn away from
you at least have to give it a try at
least the alpha brain it's the flagship
product of the company alpha brain is
made with mushrooms that helps your
memory and your focus you know i could
sit here for hours and tell you all the
benefits
but it's better if you go on the website
and read about them firsthand
why take my [__] word for it i'm a
[__] idiot i'm a ged guy
go to honor.com right now whether it's
the alpha brain
the melatonin that's [__] tremendous
to help you sleep
the protein powder puffs the shroom tech
immune
the shroom tech sport and the list
[__] grows
their supplements are number one with me
you understand me numero [__] uno
now it's up to you to say do i need this
in my life
do i need to help my focus and memories
at the beginning of the month
and i'm still walking around like in the
twilight zone i'm going to order some
[__] alpha brain
go to onyx.com right now take a look at
the selection of supplements
you're going to be [__] amazed
protein bites i mean
new mood shroom tech immune shroom tech
sport
like i said for days but we ain't got
the time
just go to honor.com right now read the
website
look at the supplements and how they can
help you press in church
and get 10 off delivered right to your
[__] house all right that's how i
roll
the joint is also brought to you by mvmt
or better known as movement watches like
i told you in the beginning of the show
valentine's day is two weeks [__]
away less than two weeks
and you're sitting there scratching your
head what am i gonna get mama what are
you gonna get mama
you're gonna get mama a beautiful watch
why get her something that she doesn't
want
roses chocolate blah how [__] boring
are you
give her a watch something she actually
likes i love my mbmt
watch they sent me the element
international waters
with the gunmetal metal gray beautiful
stunning and they also sent me the dust
sunglasses
at in black they're tremendous movement
watches
look like they cost the whole paycheck
but they cost what you used to spend on
a night out
get a beautiful watch shipped right to
your house
for free if you don't love it send it
back no worries
we don't get our feelings you don't get
your feelings hurt but if you're like me
you spend a lot of time in front of a
computer get some ever scroll blue light
glasses
to help with eye strain bad sleep and
headaches but like the founders of
movement watchers
that two college dropouts that took the
watch industry
with great looking designs and even
better prices
now all the movement watches blue light
gap glasses
and jewelry a 20 off for their
valentine's day sale
right now get on movement right now go
to
mvmt.com take a look at the fine
selection of watches
sunglasses jewelry they got it
this is for you this is what you're
looking for right now this is
if you got a husband or a boyfriend you
don't know what to give them these
watches are [__] gorgeous
they're solid you understand me so if
you don't know what to get your loved
one
go to mvmt.com
joey use code vday20 at checkout
to save 20 percent on all perfect
movement gift
for your loved ones this valentine's day
join the [__] movement
with free shipping and free returns by
going to mbmt.com
joey again that's mbmt.com
joey and use code vday20 or vday20 how's
that one for you
no fun no fun no money whatever the [__]
it is
right now go to mbmt.com
joey and take a look at the beautiful
watches they have
also take a look at that dust sunglasses
also
take a look at their jewelry listen to
me mbmt
aka movement watches are the way to go
again go to mbmp.com
joey and get free shipping and free
returns
by joining the movement and the joint is
also brought to you by
cbd lion the best
the best the best and i say this to you
now with surgical experience because now
i use them during the surgery
these all the things i'm using to help
me except for the vapors i'm not vapor
but they even have a vapor pen for you
if you want to take your cbd that way
vapor pen gummies kinesiology tape
the regular kinesiology tape a 10 foot
row
the tinctures listen you cannot go wrong
with cbd line go to cbdline.com right
now
read read learn about cbn
cbd the benefits which cbd
product is best for what you're
suffering from whether it's pain anxiety
go to cbdlion.com right now preston joey
get 10 percent off for church 20 percent
off delivered to your house
cbd lion does not [__] around
plain and simple that's it it's february
1st the rent is due
you ain't got time to [__] around i want
to thank honor
i want to thank movement watchers and i
want to thank cbd cbdlion.com
but most importantly i want to thank you
animals for [__] supporting us
and for being here with us every monday
and wednesday i love you have a great
day
pay the rent and that's it and that's
that have a great [__] week it starts
today
that's it [__]
you